بدل مشهد مالوفا لا جديد فيه فاشتعال
المواجهات غدا جزءا اصيلا من مسيرات الغضب
الفرنسي ضد قانون التقاعد
تغيب التفاصيل خلف دخان المواجهات وما ظهر
منها ينبئ بان العلاقه بين الحكومه
والغاضبين
قد انكسرت
قبل ان تصل الامور الى ما وصلت اليه من
توتر كان المشهد على هذه الحال مئات
الالاف خرجوا في كل انحاء فرنسا للتمديد
بقانون التقاعد
التعليم الثانوي لا يرى مجالا للتراجع رغم
ان كل اضراب في اي يوم احتجاج يكلفه
اقتطاعا من راتبه
[موسيقى]
لا نشعر بالتعب سنواصل الاحتجاج حتى تلغي
الحكومه هذا القانون غير العادل والذي خرج
بطريقه غير ديمقراطيه ودون التصويت عليه
تمتد موجه الاحتجاج لتشمل الفئات الاكثر
شبابا
[موسيقى]
لكن صوت الاحتجاج على قوته بدا انه يتجه
ليخفت شيئا فشيئا المقارنه بارقام فاتح
مايو تؤكد تراجعا كبيرا في اعداد
المتظاهرين هل يتعلق الامر بتعب وملل ام
هو تسليم بالامر الواقع
نائب البرلماني عن حزب فرنسا غير الخاطئه
له تفسيره الخاص لهذا التراجع
الموظف الذي يضرب مده شهرين يقسم منه راتب
تلك الفتره ان الاحتجاج والتعرض للعنف
البوليسي يدفع كثيرين الى التراجع صحيح ان
المحتاجين اليوم اقل ولكن الاستطلاعات
تؤكد ان 70% من الفرنسيين يدعمون الحركه
وهما يعني ان في البلد غضبا وان لا حل له
الا بالتراجع عن هذا القانون
المتظاهرين وبمنطق السياسه لا تعني خساره
النقابات انتصارا كبيرا للحكومه ولا
للرئيس اللذين سيكون عليهما التعامل مع
غضب متراكم لن يفوت فرصه للتعبير عن نفسه
ولو بعد حين
يدرك الرئيس وحكومته هذا الوضع تماما فقد
دعوى في اكثر من مناسبه الى الحوار
والتهدئه وما يزيد من تعقيد الوضع بالنسبه
الى الرئيس ان حكومته لا تتمتع باغلبيه
مطلقه في البرلمان
يجعلها ذلك في مرمى تهديدات حجم الثقه من
قبل المعارضه لا يحميها من ذلك الا صعوبه
اجتماع اقصى اليمين واقصى اليسار على قول
واحد في البرلمان محمد البقالي الجزيره
باريس